what I basically try to do is understand
human nature how the mind works what
makes us tick what are the patterns of
thought and emotion and motivation that
characterize our species and I focus on
language partly because you can't make a
living out of studying human nature just
do big atopic you've got to pick
something tractable to study for me it
is has been in language and indeed for
much of my career one little corner of
language namely regularly irregular
verbs and I have my reasons for focusing
on that particular corner I think it
does shed light on larger questions
about what makes the mind work but
language as a general topic is a I think
a good entree into human nature for a
number of reasons its distinctively
human if you're interested in general in
what makes humans unlike mice and birds
language is a pretty good place to start
not only because of language itself the
fact that we make noise with our mouths
in order to get ideas across
but because language has to be
fine-tuned for the kind of thoughts and
the kind of social relationships that
humans want to share and negotiate with
one another so it's a it's a window into
human nature it's also figured in
debates on human nature perhaps most
famously with Chomsky in the late 50s
using language as a way to rehabilitate
the idea of innate mental structure
something that was virtually taboo in
the 1950s he said language is a very
good candidate for something that is
innately and uniquely human
so it's an opening wedge for the idea
that that important parts of the mind
are innately structured it's also a
prime case of mental computation it's
very hard to make sense of language of
our ability to string words into new
combinations sentences that other people
have never heard before but can very
quickly understand for the first time
without appealing to the idea that we
have a mental algorithm
a set of rules or a recipe or a formula
that picks words out of a memory store
and strings them together in
combinations where the order as well as
the choice of words is meaningful so
language sheds light on the idea that
the mind is a computational system
I did what I think is the isn't for a
long time will be the most exhaustive
study of one aspect of child language
development the fact that kids make
errors like I we holdin the baby rabbits
and the alligator goat kerplunk where
they add a regular suffix like edy to an
irregular verb like hold or here or
stick producing errors like sticked and
tared and hold it I analyzed 20,000 of
those forms from computer transcripts of
children developing language and
developed a theory of why kids make that
error how they outgrow it and what it
shows about language the reason to
obsess over a tiny little topic like
that is that it's a nice illustration of
children's creativity in acquiring
language the essence of language is that
you aren't restricted to a fixed list of
messages that you've memorized and that
you then regurgitate like a parrot or
rather you you recreate me combine
elements to create new messages
every sentence that we utter is a
brand-new sentence but it's rather hard
to study the process of kids making up
new sentences when a kid says something
like sticked or tear door here or hold
it it's a tiny example of recombination
that I think is the engine that powers
language as a whole the the act of
children making an error like that I
think is a way of catching them in the
act of doing something that makes
language powerful namely combining
things by rules and in trying to
understand that one phenomenon I hope
that we my students and I shed light on
the process of linguistic generativity
or creativity in general I also tried
very hard to crack the code of what
verbs mean and how that influences how
we use them in sentences the verb is in
a way the chassis of the sentence once
you pick the verb
it's got slots that the rest of the
sentence
is built around the subject the object
the indirect object prepositional
objects and so on so knowing how the
verb works tells you a lot about how the
sentence works and how the verb works
depends on what the verb means you might
think how could you ever get your get a
handle on something as nebulous as what
a verb means but but I'd like to think
that that I cracked a lot of that code
what's the difference between a verb
like to fill in a verb like to pour and
a verb like to load they're not just
video images in the head of someone
pouring and filling and loading but
rather they have an Anatomy they built
out of parts parts like to cause to move
means versus end a let versus for versus
cause